hi there now i also want to do a video
um
you know we live in this world where we
have people
in all kinds of different you know
cultural environments natural
environments involved in different
activities
uh in my previous video i i or perhaps
it'll end up being the next video but i
compliment
benny who's located in brazil where he's
studying arabic and from brazil he's put
together this wonderful video
about people singing in different
languages
and i was recently in northern alberta
here in canada and some of you may know
that my main activity
my main career activity has been in the
forest products industry
a wonderful industry
sustainable renewable
some of the misguided environmentalists
get all excited because trees get cut
down
trees get planted and wherever you have
uh an industrial forest or an economic
forest you actually have more trees
growing than where there before
yes the ecosystem changes yes we have
seven billion people on the planet where
we used to have a few hundred million
and as a result the ecosystem has
changed you cannot freeze the ecosystem
uh
you know the world has grown warmer
colder
we have more people things change
where we operate uh generally speaking
the wildlife has been increasing with
the exception of the caribou
and we now have plans in place to
mitigate negative impacts on the caribou
uh it would appear that uh one of the
reasons is that uh
the population of
um
moose has grown and uh
therefore the wolves are who prefer to
go after moose because they're bigger
and the moose are now roaming around in
areas that were previously
uh the preserve the caribou and the
caribou are sort of solitary uh less
attracted to the wolf but as the wolf
discovers
thanks to the following the moose
discovers the caribou they're attacking
the caribou we don't know all of the
reasons why but the caribou are
declining so we're having to take steps
in our
logging practices to mitigate mitigate
negative impact on the caribou and we
will be seeing these results but our
forests abound in wildlife but obviously
things change we try in most of our
reforestation to mimic what was there
before if it's a mixed aspen spruce
forest we will try to maintain sort of a
mixed forest
uh if it was heavier to spruce we will
try to uh we will plant spruce which is
perhaps not natural because normally the
natural regeneration would be
to aspen with the bruise the spruce and
coming in underneath the aspen and most
of the forests here were typically
regenerated by forest fires caused by
you know lightning in the summer and so
forth and so on
uh but i wanted to share with you
because i recently had to go up to
manny where i'm involved with the
sawmill up there it's the annual
christmas party and of course at this
time of year it's a little chilly up
there it got up to minus 41
uh one morning
and so uh this is by way of intro to
uh the videos that i took with my iphone
i hope they turned out okay
so i you know just to let you know that
i do have other things on my mind than
just uh language learning so look
forward to
any comments you might have on these
shots that i took with my iphone thanks
for listening
and here we are in the peace country
and uh
this is
representative of what it's like you see
the in this particular forest the
popular trees power over the spruce
trees and here the spruce trees have
taken over and
basically those are the two
kinds of trees that grow in this area
poplar and spruce
the poplar typically is the first to
come back and then the spruce grows
underneath the poplar and interspersed
with these uh with the forest
is farmland and we're quite far north
here we're almost what 60 degrees north
close to 60 degrees north it's a
in a way it's a harsh
harsh climate but uh there's forest up
here
there's oil here we have a
little farm over here on the other side
looks like they've got cattle over there
there's always lots of truck traffic
here because this is the main road
up to the northwest territories here we
see some farmland again
and
we're headed towards
manning and we're about to come across
one of the early farmhouses
here uh
we see a little canadian fly we'll go by
quite quickly
as we just passed it and that's one of
the early houses here
when people came up and uh you know at a
time when they didn't have modern
conveniences and
converted this forest into into farmland
and
at certain times of the year we see the
northern lights
and uh the forest is kind of like uh
mixed hardwood
soft wood occasional
bog and marsh area and of course
farmland and fairly monotonous
in other words
for another for
many hundreds of miles in every
direction it's more or less the same
here you see a typical farm
lots of equipment
a small house and typically a large uh a
large uh
several
one sections many many acres
uh we're coming up to an area that's
here we see an area that's heavier to
spruce
may not be able to make it out here
behind that farm
and of course the spruce is
the more valuable species because it can
be used for lumber
whereas the the aspen is used for
pulp
so we're coming closer to the spruce
forest here the average
tree is going to be 90 100 years old by
the time it's harvested
and when we get closer to the sawmill
we'll show you pictures of the
regeneration because we planted
trees there some 15 years ago and you'll
see that they're growing
and the temperature is dropping so we
suspect that uh
it may even go lower what's the
prediction richard minus 28 minus 28
we're going to get to -28
but it's beautiful country it's uh
you know it's uh
flat i guess but
but the uh you know the horizons are are
are huge
and uh
the danger here when you're driving at
night
is that uh you will uh run into animals
deer will damage your car and the moose
will kill you
basically
and this is your typical farmland up
here it's very flat they grow what wheat
uh
what else rapeseed i got canola yeah
and here we see a typical farm lots of
equipment
uh they're not too active in the winter
obviously
i don't know what all those little
shacks are
and
yeah
farmland
a beautiful day plenty below is
just about ideal conditions here for the
winter
and we both agree that 40 below is not
so much months
not so much fun but uh
20 is good and the land is
quite
flat here we are at manning diversified
it's 32 below zero
and they're logging 24 hours a day and
this is a logging truck that's being
unloaded
and the button top loader is
picking up these sticks
and piling them
and here the logging basically takes
place
uh during the winter so they're just
starting to bring in wood and at the end
of three months they'll have a year's
supply
of logs uh for the mill and the mill is
right behind us here we can see it off
in the distance we'll get over to the
mill a little later but all of this
space here and there we see another load
of logs big trees
being put into the pile
and uh
yeah
and that's what it is and it's 32
degrees below zero it was uh we went uh
snowshoeing yesterday but we're not
gonna go today because it's too cold
and here we have
some further parts of the operation they
make pellets here utilizing the waste
and these pellets are shipped to homes
and increasingly they're used
in power plant
uh here we have the pellets in the
background are the dry film and the dry
films are fired by the
waste again and in the back that large
building there is the uh it's the
sawmill we won't go into the sawmill and
here we have some lumber sitting around
so
it gives you a bit of a sense of
uh yeah quite a complex
and here we are driving past the forest
that was planted how long ago
about 12 years 12 years ago and those
trees are looking about three oh four
meters tall yeah they're good enough
they're pretty big
and uh yeah so even though it's very
cold here uh the the spruce trees do
come back very nicely
and uh but still it's a good 90 years
before we have a tree that uh that can
be harvested right or do you think these
would be earlier than that maybe another
80 or so 80 years went you want to you
and i go back in there in 80 years yeah
we're gonna make a plan we're gonna
drink a bottle of wine back sounds like
a good idea i'll get a shot of real in
the picture you can
real is the general manager i'm one of
our partners here and yeah that's a nice
hey yes pine tree got in there oh maybe
the odd one the odd one okay